hey jerry we're about two hours outside
of las vegas and bullhead
city arizona where we're nearing 24
hours since the power went out and right
now 8 000 residents are still without
power we are currently at sunrise
elementary school which is serving as a
cooling shelter and throughout the day
we've seen residents coming in and out
just trying to find some relief from the
heat
sunrise elementary is one of the four
shelters that opened up right away after
sunday night's thunderstorms the storm
so severe it wiped up the power for the
entire bullhead city causing residents
to scramble to find relief from the heat
we went to the casinos across the street
and we were there until about like 4 a.m
then it got real
late so we heard about this place and
we've just been here ever since anthony
castaneda has been seeking shelter at
sunrise elementary with his family i
felt good because it was nice cold air
and then we found one of these mats on
the ground where we were able to lay on
them when did you know it was time to
leave your house when i started to get
real hot and humid the storms took up
power poles throughout the city and
mohave electric cooperative says 21
thousand residents were left without
electricity on top of that monday
afternoon brought a water outage also
believed to be caused by the power
outage it's very important to us
whenever we're in a heat advisory or a
heat warning and it's really hot outside
that we get somewhere for
our members of our community who are
sensitive to the heat to have a place to
shelter the shelters have made it very
clear that animals are allowed inside so
owners do not feel compelled to stay at
home without power or leave pets behind
he was panting really bad my son was
doing not doing so good i've had prior
heat stroke so i was just like i gotta
get out of this and we have my son's cat
and then my niece's elderly dog what are
you doing in the kettle uh i was getting
antsy and she was getting antsy so we're
in here chilling together just dealing
with it
although power is expected to be
restored in just a few hours officials
have made it very clear that these
shelters will remain open until everyone
in the city gets their power back
reporting from bullhead city arizona
victoria saha 8 news now